good morning Keith thanks for joining us
what are the stars oh boy good morning
how are you you are a star how long how
long have you been with Dateline four
hundred and two years and are you I'm
good have you been around 25 years well
off yeah I mean I started out with them
and then went away for a while today I
went up to do a morning show up in
Canada for a few years and then I came
back again in about 95 so I missed a few
years in fact I got I missed the years
where they had to do a little show
shuffling after I do the famous with the
Chevy truck nobody likes to remember
wait um
oh yes let's not even bother what do
people say to you on the street on the
street yeah huh not you again no because
normally they see you something bad has
happened
well that's true although you know most
people are very very nice and they'll
stop and chat and it's me you know maybe
take a selfie or something but
occasionally somebody will stop me who
and I remember one guy in particular who
stopped me one day and said do you have
to talk that way kept on walking how did
it come about that you did the Waze app
to you know provide directions for
people there's a devious woman who works
at Dateline who's got a fertile mind and
she's always coming up with these
strange ideas crazy ideas and I usually
backed them back and said oh that's nuts
with let's not do that and it weighs was
one of the ones where I said to her I
thought she was crazy because why would
ways even want to do that and and also
don't you have to sit and record a
million different things
turns out you don't it took me a couple
hours but it's been it's actually it's
hilarious really although I can't use it
myself it's too creepy you don't have
you giving you directions no no no I
tried at one time and it was just no no
no I didn't that's ridiculous
give me a give me a line that you had to
record that you remember ah I don't know
oh go ahead watch rapid camera watch out
so it was a couple hours where you just
go into a recording studio and then they
just give you a line the recording
studio in the closet of my house all
right
bedroom closet do you voiceover date
line from the closet in the bedroom
closet yes that's right and it's um it's
probably a better recording studio than
most any other you can find frankly that
process of trying to get it right when
you're by yourself and the granted the
acoustics in your closet are probably
great but how do you know when you've
gotten it right that really captures
what you're going to show on I don't
have an ID no idea at all none I just
say it men hope it turns out alright
anybody your family have a voice similar
to yours you know not really no yeah
it's odd isn't that I don't know how
that happened don't know no idea how
often do you try to mix in comedy or a
sense of humor in the in the dateline
reads there to lighten the mood well the
thing is these are all men but almost
all a pretty sad or or sometimes creepy
stories about terrible things that have
happened to people and so and and we
have the people who've gone through them
have been good enough to tell us about
them so first of all you respect what
they've been through and I really do I
mean it's remarkable how people are
prepared to share their stories
in in an effort to kind of not only get
their story out but to help other people
understand how to deal with these things
so you know I respect that enormously
but at the same time I understand and
the viewers understand that there is
this kind of tends to be a public
fascination with a true-crime and that
we we get some we get some probably
innocent pleasure out of watching these
stories so there is something kind of a
wink and a nod between us as you know
storyteller and story listener and I
think that's where just a little humor
hopefully self-deprecating or something
comes into it but but there is I don't
know even know what it is if it's humor
or it's just how its posed as you go to
break Polly give Keith an example of
what might make us I don't know grin a
little bit like why would the pool be
empty and a hot hot summer day you know
like it looks pretty good you know I
like that but when you when you gotta do
that later it has nothing to do with the
story you're going to use but you're
going to throw that in there why not but
i but i loved it like you leave us this
with this question like you know and
where was the dog you know where was
this what's the story that stays with
you or stayed with you the longest you
know a lot of them that there's just
there's so many that I it's it's hard to
pull up one in particular but you know
they there are there are several that
stayed with me a long time some about
crime and some not of a crime and this
was found very strange one that I was
thinking about yesterday in fact because
the subject came up for some reason
do you remember Willie Free Willy the
whale yeah this was a whale named Keiko
who was in a small pool in Mexico when
they made the movie free willy and a
telephone billionaire
saw the movie and became the cest with
with the whale built a huge pool
in Oregon in an effort to not only give
it a better home but train Willy the
whale or Keiko to be wild to be able to
be released in the ocean so this is a
process that went on for years and we
followed it I did like three or two or
three four stories about it over the
course of into several years and it was
it was a it was a remarkable story this
whale was so friendly wanted to kind of
it's almost like it was talking to you
and then later on toward the end of the
story it was sad and pathetic because
you know they called the whale the
golden the the golden retriever it just
wanted to be man's best friend and
didn't want to get out in the wild and
fish and didn't know how and and it can
do a rather sad end a few years later
but so I followed that story and
actually it's stuck with me all these
years but you still feel kind of a
fondness for that crazy whale how do you
because you're you're dealing with
negative stories it's rare when you're
saying you know Dateline is going to do
a story on something that's really a
good feeling we we don't do happy
stories right but but it has to you
bring it home with you it's like a you
know a therapist listening to sad
stories and yet true how do you process
that well it's it probably is partly in
the in the experience of talking to and
being with those who have gone through
these things they're the ones who are
having trouble adjusting or they're the
ones who have to think about it and feel
it every day having can you imagine
losing a child or a spouse or family
member to some dreadful thing like
murder you know it's a it's a terrible
idea and when you see people going
through it and they share what it's like
to go through it it's almost like I
don't have to live with it because they
told me the story they've given me
something of what it's what it's like
for them and and I feel as if that in
some cases maybe hell
a little bit and so you know he's a
Keith Morrison the one of the stars of
Dateline NBC correspondent my producer
Paul II who just did the imitation of
you sent you a line or two could you
record that could you uh read that so we
could have that four plus there oh you
mean now here of course okay all right
here all right you ready here we go okay
the Dan Patrick show a directionless
morning sports zoo with one broadcasting
legend and scoffs by a motley crew of a
deviance but it works you're listening
and watching the Dan Patrick show does
that work no yes could it be all right
wait wait you need another take I do
okay I don't know what you think III was
fine with it I thought it was pretty
good and I like to pause with deviance
well they are aren't they can you can
you give me a line of what's wrong with
the pervy guy in the back or could you
do it maybe suck it back rocky uh send
it back row it was a burden that I uh
it's always great a nutcase wrong good
hello it's a great to talk to you again
and safe travels as always but thank you
for joining us Keith thank you and it's
nice to talk to you again that's Keith
Morrison Dateline NBC correspondent what
does the pervy guy back I might have
ruined it because I laugh but III think
we got in a clean socket back row the
Dan Patrick show weekday morning on
audience
you